ciao a tutti buon pomeriggio e buon
pomeriggio ragazzi oggi era capo stata
abbastanza pregna è importante perché io
ho l'onore personale di avere frw vede
già call come ospite salve ma è per
maestro come va sono un consente adesso
ti secco mi come stavo dicendo è così
che risolveremo la fame nel mondo
invece questo format dirette sull'amore
anch'io solo che del mio format non c'è
traccia perché ogni volta che finisce
una puntata io voglio eliminò roma
rimane traccia nei cuori di tutti i
mezzi credo sia anche la cosa speciale
meravigliosa di amore amaro anche il
titolo perché secondo me il forum andata
si parla di qualsiasi cosa legata
all'amore e per quanto mi riguarda anche
io oggi vorrei portare un po di amore
amaro all'interno di questo format cioè
in chat
fateci sapere se ci sono delle cose che
come vorreste parlare devono simile che
vorreste chiedere perché pro è un
esperto pro formati di dirette tra
l'altro è nato prima l'ok da un'era tipo
aprile maggio
io ero sbronzi moacasa e faccio la cosa
più sbagliata che si fa da bree archi
prendo il telefono che il già pressione
già un errore o messaggi qua messaggi la
infatti amore amaro è nato per questo
onde evitare di contattare gente faccia
dura ancora più grande e vado in diretta
e tra l'altro la pensione si rivolgono
serve una che dato il via a questo
format e tua cugina la cugina come si
chiama non mi ricordo il nome uno dei
faccia a victoria siciliana mi ricordo
una storia di dell'olanda si allora è
stata lei la primissima papa testa
diretta stata mezzanotte ragazzi che mi
sa se parlavo più o meno aggiungendo un
po di gente a caso è arrivati a parlare
d'amore mi pare una prima anche se
sorbito questa cosa questa la prova la
tua cugina
ciao vittoria abbiamo appena parlato
vittoria che ho appena parlato di te li
fai tutta in altra gara cioè tu stai in
mezzo ne parli sempre in mezzo alle
palle praticamente
il pari è servito a perché come tender
perché ho comprato il suo infinito
abbiamo già tutto organizzato
torno a casa masanotti la vita storia
vieni subito quattro sonate op e penso
money list in cui non ci vai
non è vero carinissimo labate mandata in
sicilia prima che poi costrutti anche
questa live trovate qualcuno ci
salutiamo serbia lo sapevo di aver
parlato di giuseppe non andiamo contro
questo ragazzo analizzandolo secchia
preso in giro in realtà era interessato
gli piaceva la pannocchia ma poi
all'ultimo non varia p pop corn
non ce ne frega di questa cosa quello
che ci interessa è che questo ragazzo
che ha permesso di capire questa novità
su di te e allora vivi di questa novità
in quel davanti a quella che è una
ricerca tua perché se più non riesce
andare avanti sappi che è semplicemente
per un blocco tuo che è normale che ti
devi permettere di vivere ma là fuori
non è un mondo fatto dei speroni che
aspettano che tu compie un passo
questo è il mio parere bravo bravissimo
è un po come viaggiare se ci pensi c'è
il mondo migliore
conoscerti e un po conoscendo il mondo
fuori di de realtà la dinamica del
rifiuto non la non la skeeter è così
tanto non la vivrei in maniera così
tragica e giusto viversi il dolore
all'inizio è saggio è sacrosanto ed è
umano ad un certo punto però utilizzano
come uno strumento buono per
fortificarsi in quello che fai nei tuoi
denti danni le tue convinzioni come bp
dico un giorno saremo insieme nel regno
dei cieli
le tavole della legge sul monte fine
secondo me le persone che cadono in
queste cose qua è perché ha un po a loro
piace fare queste cose c'è ora mi mi
permetto di dire che ti piace a te
questa cosa diavolo stia litiga sta con
un'alta aiuti aspetto io ti chiedo tu e
il tempo per sarà presa questa cosa ce
l'hai non ci dimentichiamo mai che la
nostra vita dura pochissimo l'intera
esistenza dell'essere umano non di noi
adesso è l'essere umano e tipo il 2 per
cento della vita della terra prima di
tula tua vita quanto poco dura
nell'universo no siamo così minuscoli
all'interno della nostra vita che
sprecare il tempo dietro a delle cose
che sotto sotto rischiamo di utilizzare
per i crogiolarci più nella nostra
miseria perché a volte raga questa è una
cosa fondamentale scusa mi hanno
avvertito mio fratello fabiano dovete
sapere piccola brand sì che io e mio
fratello fabiano siamo dei mega fan di
guglielmo noi da altro quando abbiamo
iniziato a fare i video su youtube nel
2012 13
noi facevamo i video come willwoosh fa e
ora ma abbiamo ci sta guardando e
scritto grande live che è incredibile
essere live contestato piano abbiamo per
me è incredibile sella il conto fratello
eva ben sa quando tra pochissimi anni tu
sarai queen live perché lo avrei ucciso
sul posto quindi sarà ancora pazzesco
parleremo del tuo crimine avete letto il
mio commento col mio account
io ho avuto una storia
pazzesca tutto quanto perfetto stupendo
presenti quelle cose tipo un po alla
moccia dove guardavo il cielo è l'unica
cosa che riusciva ad esprimere era un
grazie di tutto
non più desideri quelle cose che
puntualmente si è bravissimo sembra
insomma tutta la dovrei scriverlo il
problema qual è si una roba va male
iniziamo a pensare non era poi così
perfetta è buonissima la sacher 7 sfondi
3 de pila fidati che stai successo
perché tutte le altre cose poi sono i
dolci non so non lo so è come chi ha
trovato a letto uno che proprio una che
proprio automaticamente hai capito cos'è
che cerchi esattamente non è facile
trovare quella cosa appunto starci per
entrambe le cose bisogna dare il esatto
e da vorrei ribaltare questo tipo di
domanda turbo ii che immagino che
insomma avrete tutta materie input
sicuramente più voluminose dei noi
comuni mortali
vi è mai capitato di pensare questa cosa
sai fare pd scorso al dottor frankestein
detto una cosa giustissima anzitutto ora
con i social network va ad iniziare una
frase cosiddetta coda vecchi raciti che
quello che hai detto alle persone
giudichi quello che dici tu non sei
stanco di vedere con questo giudizio non
vuoi spogliarti di questa notte dopo
bello guardavi e si è vero
col tempo sono riuscito a imparare a
fare un passo in avanti a capire che
tutti questi input che dicevo in realtà
non sono il mondo reale ma sono il mondo
che si è costruito e mi sono costruito
intorno cioè come una sorta di bolla
nella quale mi sono rinchiuso importante
rendersi conto che viviamo tutti
all'interno della nostra bolla ma ne
esistono tantissime altre l'insieme di
tutte le bolle fanno il mondo quando me
ne sono accorto ho smesso di avere
questa visione nella quale credo inizia
a desiderare è sempre quello che non hai
che però talvolta e anche un po la
maledizione dell'essere umano e quello
rimpiangere desiderare quello che non
hai in quel momento quindi da un lato
gli dico sì ho imparato a vedere oltre
ma di certo non avrò mai il campo da
questo meccanismo per trovare un
equilibrio è sempre la chiave della
felicità e dopo che c'era quanti invece
è bella bella considerazione ragazzi io
ho un problema ed è un problema che
esattamente rientra in quello che ha
detto adesso bachini jackson
io mi trovo a aver provato determinate
sensazioni con le persone chiacchiere
pazzesche sesso assurdo io ho degli e le
varie persone alle quali attribuisco
diciamo la medaglia d'oro di determinate
cose
[Risate]
complimenti come abbiamo chiamato
consente accademico le migliori
telefonate a quando hanno fatto un bel
mag azzardo tutti voi premiarli io non
posso avere o è molto difficile o magari
arriverà una persona che mi farà andare
oltre tutti questi primati ma è molto
difficile avere una persona che
racchiuda tutti quei primati insieme
perché sono primati così alti e non fate
sorrisini pensando solamente a quelle
cose di nome fa c'era un commento e dice
quello che c'è il lato b più bello
new york miglior lato a la cordici nera
il doppio a ha all attivo a persona
se ci fosse il corpo di quello con
quello di quello di quello con la
capacità di quello con la divertimento
di quello con la tenerezza di quello che
mi tira fuori con la voglia di stare
insieme con lui verrebbe fuori la biesse
ardente vabbè ma noi
noe sam idee siamo abituati a dirlo e
tanker un grande protettore cattivo la
mia vita è invece di chiudermi
all'interno dell'ansia del dover per
forza avere una relazione in questo
momento poi soprattutto rimango aperto
quel che madonna per me è uguale ogni
giorni parola una cosa che viene detta
molto online
etichette nelle certezze cerchi invece
vuoi veramente generare voci sono delle
chat che possono essere i tender il
grinder non piace che rendere presente e
la chatta quella ritmo
immaginiamo un po troppo spinta per i
miei gusti ma l'ha capito
nel frattempo lo scarico esatto no no no
non so se del tuo interesse però sappi
che ci ritrovi ammazzi come gli asparagi
però non so se non sento le ranta gli
asparagi il discorso mio sai cos'è che
non mi pesa la vita è una meravigliosa
vetrina passerà davanti a un negozio se
c'è una cosa che veramente cogliere il
mio sguardo vorrà dire che vorrei
comprarla che vorrei averla è da molto
che non sono in mutande e non ho bisogno
di coprirmi ma sono perfettamente
vestito perché io mi sono vestito da
solo semmai passano davanti una vetrina
e dirò che me la sciarpa che perché
appunto vorrà dire che farò sarà in
campo per creato in circa noi cercano ma
come diceva il buon guglielmo siamo
tutti aperti in base a quello che capita
poi quello che dico sempre io l'amore
liquido si adatta al contenitore quindi
poi capiamo la forma del nostro
bicchiere quale no non è però la peta
luca ha lavorato prima almeno ci
provammo pure noi qualche aneddoto che
quotidiana ci facciamo i posso fare una
domanda invece nel caso tutte la prima
con il capo le che intervenuto posti non
ti preoccupare la commentiamo gli altri
a ok ok obbligati a scegliere tra una
persona di che attrae da morire
fisicamente faccio questa domanda voi
per avere una ridotta io nella mia vita
privata
una persona che ti fa impazzire sotto il
profilo fisico bat pietro de fantaghirò
a livello morale cioè presente il fatto
che fantaghirò arido distesa brulla di
voto e dall'altra parte invece hai una
persona che fa un perfetto match mentale
ma c'è una grandissima attrazione fisica
la persona con la quale ho una forte
attrazione fisica e brava tromba
certo sto leggendo un sacco di nessuno
dei due bisogna scegliere troppo facile
ma è una domanda assurda
no è difficile assurda certo come tutte
le cose della mia vita benvenuto con
risposte però sarà irrealistica
preferisco una persona che mi piace
fisicamente perché poi la connessione
mentale la faccio da solo invece è
l'amore da solo è infatti di un parte di
chi costoso molto spesso è capitato che
un compatibilità mentale con qualcuno
mina anche molto all'attrazione rotea di
cena prendete cioè decreto contestato
dai trovando un enorme con terzo frw non
lo farei mai in realtà è malposta la
domanda che razzismo dovevi dirlo prima
così risponde io sono d'accordo che tra
le due cose preferisco la persona bona
con la quale trombo bene perché
esattamente come per la connessione a
faccia sono convinto che ci troviamo su
tutto e negati bribon perché merate il
91 per cento annunciato invece ha detto
che preferisce la persona che è
mentalmente mi prende arriviamo però al
bar by perchè solitamente nella mia
esperienza mi ha attirato molto
fisicamente c'è chi mi ha preso molto è
vero gli applicato un sacco di
sovrastrutture ha però chi tipica
mentalmente è molto più bravo tra un
mare di quello ben destino infatti
infatti è questo che mai cosa molto
molto
noi abbiamo preso l'incompatibilità
mentale così un po come un gioco ma in
realtà essere incompatibili mentalmente
può significare tante cose
parliamo a questo punto di attrazione
fisica e capacità e erotica se doveste
scegliere
basta se scelte sono stati coesi invece
c'è chi deve mandare le sonde su marte
non la devono fare dei calcoli difficili
di roma
il no del vivere il sesso per l'uomo
talvolta non so come dire nel modo più
carino possibile per un uomo talvolta
una persona che ci piace solo
esteticamente ma anche non è
particolarmente performante a letto
talvolta può bastare una performance
quale è questo segreto e non sto capendo
qual è questo segreto che si nasconde
tra queste due parole cosa sembra se non
fossimo online 3 andando dritto al punto
invece lascio questo peso deve essere
live cercare di essere delicato perché
ma mi amano stia vedendo la mamma sicuro
sta guardando mamma frw buonasera signor
a noi le facciamo le mie delle nostre
più sentite scuse siamo lusingati simi
subito nel diciamo lo diciamo e devo
dire che doveva dirmi terra difficile
imparare a suonare ma visto come sono
stato bravo a questa parte del
imbarazzato mamma mia che ma come ti è
venuta che l'ha scritto tutto ha vinto
frw innanzitutto ti ringrazio ma non di
cuore però di spaccio comunque durare
soltanto nella propria vita e come il 2
per cento della vita di un essere a
ragione dedicate a noi per me questo che
vuol dire tantissimo grazie mille frutti
voglio bene cir anche di fare
vediamo presto che i ragazzi ciao grazie
a voi ciao a tutti ajaccio dove volete
voi
[Musica]